so we've heard from some extraordinary
investors who simply think I'm not
saying the Fed is asleep at the wheel
but Howard Marks of oak tree said the
Fed is behaving like they are completely
scared scared of the markets scared to
do anything and that's reckless steve
schwarzman of Blackstone wrote an op-ed
for The Wall Street Journal over the
summer where he said the cause of the
next financial crisis will be the
government will be regulators so there's
a big negative sentiment around the feds
in action from notable investors are
they just wrong I think they are I think
you have to balance the risks we'd all
prefer that the economy was stronger and
that the right thing to do was to raise
rates but wishing it doesn't make its so
you know seven central banks around the
world the last few years have followed
the reasoning of the people you quote
these so well things are a bit better
and zeros a problem and so will raise
rates and seven central banks that
raised rates have had to retreat and
pull them pull them right back that's
not what the feds credibility needs but
you know Stephanie last May I was on the
other side I thought the right thing to
do was to keep rates at zero which is
what the Fed did but I can see how last
May you could reasonably have made the
argument that there was growing
enthusiasm that we had zero we've been
at zero for a long time and it was time
to raise rates I don't see how you can
look at third quarter growth forecasts
that are running at about one and a half
percent one and a half percent that is
pretty close to stall speed and when
you're at stall speed and you slow down
it's not good what happens next I don't
see how you can look at where we are
right now and then say that this is the
right time to be hitting the brakes
rather than the accelerant and are you
saying they've missed the window and
that you could have happened should have
happened no I was missing no no I was
pretty careful what I said what
what I said Megan I said I was against
it in May but I understood much better
the argument in May unbalanced I still
think the risks of tipping the economy
into recession and deflation exceeded
any benefit that would come from an
increase in May but I can see what the
argument is in a context of the current
volatility turmoil and uncertainty in
the rest of the world in the context of
the current much greater signs of
incipient deflation or low flashin in
the United States in the context of the
current slowing of growth it's really
very very hard for me to see the
argument for locking in a rate increase
but I think the feds on the right wicket
when it talks about being data dependent
and monitoring the data the data may
come in the data may come in pointing to
sharply rising inflation and if when if
and when it does I will be the first to
say that it's time to raise rates but
the last time America fought a
pre-emptive war in Iraq it didn't work
out so well oh and I think of
pre-empting comparison I think a
pre-emptive war against inflation right
now would be a serious policy i want to
turn